before we get started we want to remind
you that we have the Bleak Creek
conversations coming up at the end of
October at the beginning of November
it's a live show it's very special we're
gonna be there for it and then a very
special special Bleeker conversation on
Sunday November 3rd in Los Angeles where
you can meet and greet some of the
mythical crew members including cotton
candy Randi and more and then of course
we've got some more tour stops the
regular live and concert tour at the end
of November all the details for that are
at Rhett & link live.com to visit do you
know what it doesn't take the commitment
to go to red link like comm just check
it out see where we're gonna be tell
people who you know in the area or show
up we'll make it special we promise we
will now on with the biscuit welcome to
ear biscuits I'm red
and I'm Linc survivor of a pyramid
scheme whenever I introduce myself now
that's what I'm gonna add cuz that's
what I want to be known as okay the guy
who escaped a pyramid scheme are you
gonna skip over the thing that we say at
the beginning of every podcast this week
at the roundtable of dim lighting we're
gonna answer the question how did I link
the guy who escaped a pyramid scheme
escape a pyramid scheme okay you've got
me I've clicked you want to be able to
hear anything unless you would have
somehow right-clicked play someplace so
we're gonna explore that question and
these are we're gonna explore that via a
question that we received from a
mythical beast and some other questions
that we received we're gonna give our
best we're putting our advice hats on
we're gonna be talking about multi-level
marketing our personal experiences with
that they might have we might work up
some ire it's Mike we might get angry
well we might get happy when I laugh
when I cry I think we might offend
somebody think you might get angry yeah
I think I don't think it's about us
getting it I think some people will feel
attacked you know but that will be
unintentional if that happens before we
get into those questions do want to say
we got a lot to be excited about around
here it seems like every single year at
the end
the year like starting around October
October's of things get busy for the
retsoor in the links a mythical month
you know we always got things happening
in the month of October October 11th
your birthday my birthday but we got of
course our novel the lost causes a bleak
Creek coming out on October 29th and the
Bleak Creek conversations and all that
goes along with that but we're doing
something very very special we are
celebrating with a Carolina classic what
we're gonna throw a big pig-picking
party here at the mythical studio Makana
the Bleak Creek barbecue bonanza and two
very special guests and their guests
will be chosen at random and here's how
we're gonna do that and flown to Los
Angeles to have the pig pick it with us
yeah and here's how we're gonna do that
so if you've pre-ordered the the novel
at any time in the past or you preorder
the novel now or you got a ticket to
bleed Creek conversations you go over to
bleak Creek calm you enter that proof of
purchase you can enter each proof of
purchase for a book counts once but you
can buy as many books as you want and
enter for yourself you just can't keep
putting the same one back in over and
over again and then we're going to
randomly select two of those people and
we have to say for legal purposes no
purchase necessary to enter void where
prohibited and full details on the
website but in a non-legal sin freak
dot-com we are super excited about that
and it's gonna we're doing we're gonna
do it as authentically as we possibly
can like doing it worth doing with pig I
mean that and there's a very that's I
don't know I can't stand by that
statement anything worth doing is worth
adding is worth doing with a pig picking
okay good pig pickin which is the scene
of of the opening chapter of lost causes
a bleak Creek is a pig picking yeah and
it's also what we have used to signify
big moments in our lives at least
growing up so we're like why don't we
bring this to LA can't you do a pig
pickin in LA let's figure out how and
this brings a mythical beast out
pre-order the book it's good
everybody you want to go ahead and get
into one of these questions though yeah
after the break we'll get into the
multi-level marketing but I want to give
we have a question about showers and
it's a good occasion for me to give an
update on your shower advice from last
week because I did take it but let's
read this ok read the question this
question comes from falling star girl
my boyfriend leaves the shower curtain
open after he takes a shower it drives
me nuts I don't like the inside of my
shower being exposed plus I spend I
spent good money on the curtain to
complete my bathroom decor what do you
guys think of this so so he leaves the
shower open but the curtain I would call
that meaning the curtain is scrunched
he's closed up on itself but which
leaves a shower open we all know what's
that I don't think anyone needed that
clarification well you know but I know
your brain works in a strange way so I
needed a it's fine that you said it out
loud yeah I mean I'm feeling your pain
cuz if you leave us if you leave a
shower curtain scrunched up it starts to
get that pink stuff on it how on earth
of all the things that could grow even
in a damp shower like environment how
could it turn off shower curtain pink do
you know what I'm talking about thing
that might be from you and your family
my family doesn't generate pink mould
you've never seen like a pink residue on
a shower curtain I've seen it growing up
I've seen like a girl remember scene
that way maybe like a brown mildew of
some kind but Punk that might have been
something else I could have been an
alien alright I distinctly remember we
had like you know you got the decorative
shower curtain which might be made of
fabric or something but then you got the
plastic shower curtain on the inside
which you know keeps all the moisture in
and that thing became pink at the bottom
and slimy from slimy well thankfully her
might have been because of the the the
pyramid scheme I currently do not have
to deal with a shower curtain because
our shower has a door and actually the
last every house I've ever lived in in
California has had a shower door and
that
shower-curtain must be because of the
earthquakes you don't want you don't
want that curtain wrapping around you
during a but during the big one you
don't have a bathtub with a shower in it
that's really when you got you know you
got to have a shower curtain when I'm
taking a shower in a bathtub but I know
growing up how I grew up my brother and
I had you know to traditional bathtub
with a shower in it and I know that we
kept that thing open all the time cuz it
was just a boys bathroom in my and I
know my mom would come in there after
she cleaned things up and like close it
again and then we would just open it
again because like why I I just yeah I
feel your pain I don't know how to how
you motivate your boyfriend because it's
one of those things that like if you
really there's so many things that I
care about you know it's like I go in
after my kids and I turn off the lights
and I close their drawers and I pick up
their clothes and towels off the floor
like I cannot get my sons to pick up the
towel I'll sing a lot Lincoln I can't
get him to pick up the towel off the
floor or like the clothes that he took
out before he got in the shower and I've
tried all types of things and I I have
not succeeded I don't know how to do it
and you know you know how it's gonna
stop just don't don't go in there when
they move out and then they because when
you're managing I know but she doesn't
just want a boyfriend to move out she
wants to have some sort of hope I just
wit I wish I had a simple solution I
mean it's the right thing to do not just
for decorative purposes but also for
sanitary purposes maybe if you like take
a microscopic image of that slimy stuff
that he's helping create it's kind of
like when you look under your
fingernails the stuff under your
fingernails in our microscope you won't
you won't bite your fingernails anymore
well what if I mean when did you
recently what did you recently show me
videos of what you was this a mythical
society thing where you showed me videos
of you going around your kids yeah oh
yeah yeah that's right
I I I tried I got so frustrated going
behind him and turning off the lights
and picking up all the stuff that I
would I would video me doing all of it
and then send them the video but at the
key point you're leaving out is you
would make
disgruntled sounds without speaking you
would just communicate like the way that
humans communicated before we had words
I was grunting
grunting your disgust and your
disappointment on it when the second
video I kept saying why why why are
these underwear in the sink I think you
should stick with this hey stick with
the grunts man what don't don't resort
to language because you're trying to
connect with a deeper part of their
brain like the impulsive part of their
brain that yeah we're not talking about
the neocortex at this point right you're
trying to get down into the instinctive
parts of the brain to change deeply
rooted behaviors so I think that what
spalling Stargirl could do is she could
video herself first of all get a
close-up of the wrinkled-up shower
curtain and hopefully some mold even if
you need oh you like my idea even if you
need to add a little mold to get some
kind of culture started then you get you
and you get a close-up of that and you
make up whatever you're disgruntled
sound is and then you've you have
yourself opening the shower curtain
again you're not saying anything you're
not confronting them in the moment
you're not confronting them at when he's
at the house you just sent in these
videos and you do it every single day
eventually he's going to get tired of
seeing these videos and then he'll start
it'll change his behavior I did it two
days in a row and then my kids just kind
of they laugh at me it just wasn't that
effect it's so much easier first of all
she's dealing with an adult man and I'm
not you're really saying you're dealing
with oh you did you're dealing with
children and also your
what you're doing is intruding in some
respects on their space I know you're
you're their dad but you're going into
like their personal personal area and
doing like a controlling dad kind of
thing this is the shower that they share
so you know I feel like this is a
slightly different territory but I think
your technique is sound I just think she
needs to take your - you need to stop
your technique and she have a transfer
it to falling star girl and she needs to
do it on a regular basis and I think it
will impact the behavior of her
boyfriend I think something really
embarrassing needs to be inside the
shower that he's gonna want to hide by
closing the curtain like a picture of
him naked yeah even when he's not in the
shower naked he's always in the shower
naked cuz you know when he's inside the
shower naked he closes it because he
doesn't want to expose himself but if
you take a picture and then go to like
what is that big head comm it's a place
you can get things blown up to like
paste onto the wall not a sponsor not a
sponsor I don't even know if that's it
but I think that is it take a picture
with a high-res camera you know when you
blow things up you want it to be you
don't the detail to be there and then
you just vinyl paste him on the inside
of the shower now you've got to deal
with that when you take a shower but he
will I guaran-damn-tee you he will close
that shower curtain from here on out
don't forget about the videos or you
could just use like permanent marker and
just write his secrets inside of the
shower
yeah that is fun though yeah I want to
get in the shower I want to hear your
update but what is it Fathead comm not
again I want to hear your update but
this just remind me just because I
wanted to ask if you remember this when
you were in England I noticed it in
Scotland but then when we got to England
until we got to like the London hotel
which had a normal walk-in shower with a
door every single shower that I used in
the UK no shower curtain and I'm talking
bathtub with shower built in so
traditional mm-hmm but there's a there
is a go
ass door that is on a swivel that only
goes halfway down the bathtub so did you
see this I saw it in five different
places so there's a bathtub and then
there's like a plexiglass wall built
above the bathtub that then only goes if
he goes from like the you know you got
the shower head coming out of oh yeah
coming from that wall you hands out
three quarters it comes out half 50% of
the way not three quarters so yeah so
it's so when you're standing in the in
the tub taking a shower all the water
and you're standing in the middle of the
tub that's where the plexiglass ends and
it the water bounces off of you it's
assuming that no water goes past you Oh
if the water passes you would hit I mean
listen I'm an American I guess I shower
in a particular American Way because
what I found is that in my dad and my
mom and my brother and my sister-in-law
and my wife and everybody that was with
me was like we're getting water all over
the floor
when we went to London we had the same
thing yes what is what what is it what
do we what are we doing wrong or what
are they doing wrong because this is not
a good design how is this a good design
yeah I mean water is all over the floor
that it did happen to me in the Airbnb
that we're staying and what are we
missing
could you just hashtag ear biscuits
explain that to us know on the internet
because I don't know do you guys wear
like a large sponge while you shower
that absorbs all the excess water I
don't know how you overcome this there's
there's like constantly trying to block
all of the water and bounce it back I
don't want to be thinking about that
when I'm shouting right it's high
pressure well low pressure in some
places it's well if it's low pressure
that helps but it's a high pressure
situation yeah anxiety I also I have a
door on my shower not a shower fully
seals oh yeah but the thing that I'll do
is when I get out of the shower i annoy
Christie because I leave the door open
so that all of the moisture in this shot
of the shower can can dissipate more
quickly than if you closed if you seal
it back up and then it just stays wet
and I think that's when you start to
produce bacteria starts to grow anymore
I fear that pink slime I've noticed
but then Christie's has told me a couple
of times that it's a totally clear glass
door that when I leave it open she's
she's ran into it often times so now I
have to just leave it cracked a little
bit just leave a little gap in it
you think about a lot of other things
than the things that I think about I
know I'm gonna die young we're gonna die
young ma'am but I've thought so hard
I've never thought about this particular
thing I just get out of the shower I
don't know why can't I couldn't tell you
what happens
well this morning and yesterday morning
and for well yep I well I've tried it a
few times I've tried your advice
okay stare down I get in the shower I
look out the window on the previous
podcast you told me don't try to hide
from your neighbor when he's driving
into work leaving is just just give him
than a slur assert your dominance right
well I'm lathering up here he comes
getting in his car he's facing me
sitting in the driver's seat
before he puts it in reverse and looks
behind him I'm like instinctively
started hunting I was like come on Linc
pull it together moment of truth be
dominant you know I was I was actually
washing my face at the time so I had to
stop so I could stare at him so my
forehead was flat it up okay this is
changing everything
I got a lathered up forehead I don't
know I don't know I already done the
shampoo so was I yeah I had a low lather
writer at the brow okay and I'm just
looking at the guy hoping that he does
not look at me
but it's he's not close enough that I
can immediately tell you know with the
reflection on the windshield and
everything and I'm like maybe he'll put
it reverse it take off right I can tell
he put it in reverse and then he's like
gonna look over his shoulder and
apparently he wasn't looking at me until
he started to look over his shoulder to
back up and I noticed he started to turn
and then Boop he looked back he had
noticed something right me yeah naked
bathing man neighbor asserting his dumb
with the light lather on his forehead he
saw me he definitely saw me and I just I
held your ground I did I flinched
but I didn't duck I didn't like I didn't
like boy and I fall down I flinched and
then I I don't even think he picked up
on the flinch and then I just I just
looked at him and he liked it he looked
at me man and then he put it in reverse
and he took off
look can I see what the stare is that
you're making it's a long ways like
picture sides on my forehead you know my
cuz I'm realizing that my advice could
backfire at this point I was washing my
face because if you have a special face
brush because I'm washing my you're
doing it okay look at me
alright I'm washing my forehead with the
face brush I got a special brush from a
face
it's round I go in a circular pattern
like my mom taught me back when I used
to use her Noxzema she's like this is
how you you don't get it son
wash your face in a circular pattern so
I have my own face brush and I'm doing
that and then all of a sudden I see him
I see him up there he is and I like I
lower the face brush and I just this
just what I did that's a look yeah don't
blame it on a look he couldn't see the
detail I you knew I was looking at him
[ __ ] I do know that I should have
practice because that look can be
misinterpreted as you're interested what
know it I'm just lucky I'm just I'm just
I mean you're in your shower though
think about it for a second
it's got to be intimidating almost like
children of the collect lowering the
eyebrows I just can't seem what here's
the least bits it does nothing that
you're gonna say now it's helpful
because it's too freaking late the next
day after that I'm taking a shower and
I'm like oh yeah this stare down and
I'll look out there the car is gone oh
you won he leaves it a different time
leaves a different time you forced his
hand
yeah he goes to work earlier yeah he's
like I'm not gonna do this and cuz you
get I even probably was like man he
takes a shower at the same time every
day and he's finally stared me down I
think he wants more from their
relationship either way you've won no he
sent he's thinking that about me he
thinks I want more for the relationship
from the neighborly banter must move
beyond it so now he's he's got a void
all I'm saying was it when is the
mailbox I don't know what I'm gonna do
well that's that's a different that's a
completely different mo at that point
act like act like nothing happened yeah
yeah yeah that's friendly neighbor it
situation right that's like hey man how
you doing how you been hey I haven't
been looking at you from my shower I
haven't seen you in a while while in my
shower naked lathered and myself up
that's a different link you that's the
again that's the link that needs to be
brought out in case of emergencies not
the everyday friendly link or you know
business as usual link so mission
accomplished then yeah that's very
awesome okay cool
we've got more questions but first we're
going to promote something I don't know
what is it is it are we gonna promote
the website in the store and the things
that you can buy at the store Kiko or is
there something else
let's say mythical calm mythical calm
just so much you can you can Brown we
just keep putting new stuff up there
it's fun I mean it's becoming like a
online mall shopping mall it's just like
a mini mall yeah that's what it's
becoming I mean I love it I go on there
and just scroll we got gift certificates
over there because there's so many
options at this point it's almost like
Amazon what am I gonna get you from
Amazon I'm gonna get you the ability to
get whatever you want from Amazon and a
gift card well and you if you have an
Amazon gift card you can go to our
Amazon store that's true that what I
mean we've got all the bases covered
that's what we specialize we put yeah
listen you need to keep wearing stuff
you need to keep it fresh so we're gonna
keep designing stuff and it's gonna be
fresh yeah
and we're gonna get a great team
designing crap we're gonna make sure
that you don't look like you shop at one
place that's what it's always a little
bit different everything's a little bit
different where'd you get that oh well I
got it at the same place I got it in
mythical calm but loose its differ
isn't it and you're different there's
something different about you you're
cool and that's why you shop at mythical
dot-com I'm different
yeah I'm different all right how about
another question you want to ask it
sure sure this gets into the to the
pyramid scheme stuff oh gosh we're going
Nicki nin asked a friend put that down
me a friend has been brainwashed by an
MLM scheme well tell us how you really
feel about it
she's been roped into all the feel-good
seminars and is losing money she's
become a bad friend because all caps
everything comes back to the MLM message
you joked about it in your song friends
till the end but how would you handle
this situation now we talked about our
opinions on MLMs before but weak about
to go back to the whale and I mean I
know you have a story I need a life
experience you have an anecdote I want
to say a couple of things first of all I
know some of you listening
are involved in MLMs and let's be
specific
it could be am way it could be Herbalife
it could be
Herbal life it could be Mary Kay it
could be what's the one um what's the
one we make fun of in a song loo loo loo
loo loo loo loo loo loo ro is that
that's it with the leggings leggings but
she had to go when she joined Lela row
yeah pampered chef I think does this
still around huh so let me say a couple
where parties from back I'll say a
couple of things we use the term pyramid
scheme in the question at the top
impossible in the title of this video I
don't know let me just say first of all
pyramid schemes and MLMs are not the
same thing and people who are in MLMs
are very offended by being called a
pyramid
and so I want to recognize that right
off the bat that pyramid schemes are
illegal right there it's a scam they
might be better described as a pyramid
scam and usually in a pyramid scheme
there's actually no quality product or
product at all in it you get paid for
recruiting and it's kind of this like
circular well it's actually a pyramid
but it's all based on deception and it's
it recognized as illegal from the
Federal Trade Commission whereas an MLM
multi-level marketing I'm not even gonna
use this scheme a more multi-level
marketing company usually has a viable
product that is being sold and can be
sold to someone who's not a member of
the thing but people get commissions or
people get Commission's on sales and
also people are encouraged to recruit
other people to sell so in like the
multi levels to the marketing which
could be likened if you were to draw it
as a pyramid it is an aspect of it
because it's you're you're not just
selling something but you're trying to
get people to sell things underneath you
so that when they sell you get it not
only they get a commission but you get a
commission off of their sales I mean and
then that may be used to go up that may
not happen in every one of these that
goes up the middle up the levels yeah
and and the pyramid get the levels or
there's less people as you go up until
it goes up to one person who's in charge
but the product that's being sold is not
a scam right in a reputable MLM which I
think all the ones that we just
mentioned are presumably reputable
they're legal yes so but the thing that
we want to talk about is specifically
what being a part of one does to your
friendships and relationships because it
does if especially if not managed
properly change the dynamic yeah and as
an outsider sneaking in a friend of
someone who's inside of this thing
her experience is is pretty common you
know she has a negative view of what her
friend being involved in the MLM because
of the way it's impacting their
relationship she's a bad friend because
it always comes back to her either to
the MLM message which is hey you should
buy these products from me or hey you
should also sell these products there's
an a a lot of people get involved they
they don't they don't have they're
looking for a very flexible job they're
looking for something that you can do
from home you can do from home you can
you can set your own hours and and
there's a promise of of being very
lucrative side-story
when I worked at IBM there was a stent
where my boss on the side was involved
in an an MLM and the only reason I knew
this because one day he asked me to go
to lunch with him oh he had never asked
me to go to lunch with him before I mean
I go to meetings and he's there and like
we have sometimes they have a meeting in
his office we're like you know I would
be held accountable to the stuff I was
supposed to be working on but I never
just go to lunch with a guy he was a
nice enough guy we'd go to lunch
I'd like the some restaurant around the
IBM campus yeah in and we get our food
and we sit down you know what what is
about to happen all of a sudden no I'm
like okay we're just getting to lunch
hey just lunch just lunch there's never
just lunch like get this dude all of a
sudden he he pulls out of his briefcase
oh he has a briefcase
he had like a like a a wedge like a
cardboard wedge he puts it on the table
it's just made a cardboard didn't want
you to sit on it if it was a it was a
pyramid no well it was a it was a wedge
and then it was a presentation tool he
put yes he pulled out a spiral-bound
landscape oriented notepad and then he
flip freaking book and he stood and he
searched open up the flip book and he
puts it on the thing he was like
you know I just want to tell you about
an opportunity for you to be your own
boss and make some extra money on the
side a red flag as I as I've been doing
um this is before laptops apparently I'm
like this is my freaking what we worked
for a company that made laughs dude had
a spiral-bound we gotta admit there's
more drama in it though because he
breaks out that you have to break out
the stand I start you break out the
notebook it's not it's sweating I'm like
what what is he is he assembling a
cardboard weapon do I need to leave
before it before becomes fully closed we
were in public it wasn't like this is a
Clinton it's like come to my garage you
know which I think being in public makes
it all the more embarrassing because
anyone who sees you knows that you're
now on the receiving end of an MLM like
presentation and we've both I'm sure
you've seen it I've seen people having
to endure what I was in during get this
dude I'll never forget it okay dude the
first slide man when he when he flipped
it over the first slide was a stock
image uh yes a stock image of a of the
sports car oh this cool no a red one
convertible it was a it was a sport it
was a red sports car yeah this could be
yours would you like to drive this and
he has like and he had this I mean it's
not like the dude had people skills in
normal life but something made him like
he became this weird Android and he's
like he's like um do you do you like
fancy cars and I'm like no you know I'm
not rose that book honestly I was like
have you seen my car I'm not really I'm
not really no I'm not really into sports
cars I I've never really gotten that is
there a pickup picture that you can
paste over this one yeah you know what
you can do with the notebook I drove a
non extend cab tacoma at the tire
remember that like a barely i had to get
in at sideways had to put my legs over
your over your lap in order to ride with
i
I told him I wasn't into cars and then
he's like he's unfazed he's like and he
flips out how about women it was a
mansion Oh Rican about Sharia gal have a
mansion and I well actually no I I know
I was like I'm a lot to clean I was like
a lot of showers that to be closed a lot
a lot of potential for pink slime to
crop up I prefer a have you heard of a
tiny house that was before tiny houses
why are you crying
you think you're so funny he's so funny
right now and you are funny yeah but
you're not so funny to make yourself cry
yet well I mean that would you rub your
eye re my cry was funny in a like I feel
like I've been funny for like three
times in a row yeah yeah you really you
really need to start weeping so I'm like
uh you know Christine I just got married
you know this and we're house-sitting
for a couple I mean I mean yeah well I I
would like a big house someday but I I'm
not really into that well what does he
get on the next page so he's like and
he's like well what about and I don't
remember what the picture was but it was
a picture what a weird way to I mean why
do you say do you want more money I mean
cuz most people would be like yes why
why you got to attach monetary value
what to what you anticipating what I'm
gonna like I know it's so weird
he flips it over and now he's hitting me
with would you like to give more to
charity oh I was like okay so are you
about to present a charity no he's about
to present a multi-level marketing
campaign so if I join he makes more
money no so that he can get that house
in that car man yeah but he's guilty me
with chair what am I supposed to know
I'm not really interested in giving more
to charity I think it's a
choose-your-own-adventure thing he
probably wasn't just going to the next
page because I think they teach you in
the presentation they're like you think
it's like a nine one flip when you meet
someone who is not into material things
go to charity yeah well and then if they
don't like charity you should probably
end the mean
let me tell you something brother he
didn't skip a slide okay so this is to
catch everybody and that's how it's
designed he's going on the script and it
was so uncomfortable it wasn't fair you
know it it it makes me angry even now
because this dude's my boss I mean it's
like I'm not supposed you know it's not
appropriate you felt pressured yeah it's
like you can't could have easily felt
pressured yeah you have you have power
over me as my boss and now I've got to
what I got a start and please train me
how to go up to strangers in this
magazine section of Barnes & Noble
that's happened me twice and it has
alright Nobel in North Carolina that
happened we're people who won they
started conversations with me and like
the coffee shop section and I was like
this guy's being friendly and it was
that it was it was MLM stuff it's not
worth it to be that person because you
have to you get to a point where you got
to sell your wares and again I cannot
remember what company was with or what
he was selling but you get to a point
where you're either going up to strength
you're being weird to strangers in in
Borders bookshop back in a day or you're
hitting up your friends and relatives
and every time you're talking to and
there's a whole Facebook component to it
now well that's what happens that is
what and I'm not really on Facebook and
my wife isn't really anymore but she was
for many years and that's what would
happen you would have someone who you
haven't spoken with since high school
yeah who reaches out and asks a question
you're like hey how I haven't spoken you
in a long time how are you doing and
then you respond to them and they're
like I couldn't help but notice I'm
gonna find some segue into talking about
how you need this particular product and
it's like I don't feel like we have to
explain while that why that seems kind
of just dirty and deceptive I understand
that listen I get it we sell things all
the time we just tried to sell you some
stuff at mythical calm but I think that
we're being pretty straightforward with
like okay yeah we sell merch go to the
store and buy it if you want to but I
don't try to sell my emerg directly to
my friends
and that I thought I have relationships
with and also I'm not trying to then get
them to sell it because I just don't
want my friendships to be defined by
that it just I I don't I know how it
makes me feel I know how you felt in
that situation and I know how it makes
me feel when I feel like someone is
trying to enter into a transactional
relationship with me and listen coming
from two people who live in Los Angeles
which is the most transactional town on
the plate the place of the Fannett the
face of the planet
anytime you begin to sense that someone
is investing their time into you because
of what you can do for them financially
it just feels bad man icky and when you
join an MLM you are now I'm sure there's
people obviously humans are tend to
rationalize things so I'm sure there's
people who listen right now in first of
all you're if you're benefiting from it
financially or you've moved way up into
the organization there's absolutely
nothing I can say that's going to change
your mind because you're going to
deflect anything that we say it makes
you feel uncomfortable because you got
confirmation bias you want to continue
to confirm the fact that you're in this
thing and make it okay and that's fine
I'm not trying to take you out of it I
think what we're talking to is we're
actually talking to what was her name
sneaking in and how you deal with
someone who's in it so we're not talking
to the person who's in it that's your
deal but if you've got a friend who's in
it I just think the short answer is you
have to be honest because the
alternative is just like I'm not gonna
be your friend anymore
have a boundary conversation listen I'm
not comfortable with lacing our
friendship with ulterior motives you
know I don't like questioning whether
you're whether you want me to buy
something or help you sell things and
then I think there's probably a lot of
people who in after they hear that from
a friend will be like oh I'm sorry if
that's the way you feel our friendship
will have absolutely nothing to do with
my involvement in this thing and I'll
never talk about it you feel no pressure
from me I at that point sure you can
have a help
friendship and I'm sure that's how
people who have found a way to maintain
healthy friendships manage their
relationships but the moment you cross
that line you you just have to think
with any potential friend that you have
the moment that you make it about the
MLM there's really no going back unless
the person is just going to be super
honest with you and you're gonna over
what's the other person in the difficult
situation that sneaky nin is in that now
they have to be the one to like have
this awkward conversation with you when
it's really this is really all you're
doing yeah you know it's like you've put
them in an awkward position and you can
rationalize and say well they'll tell me
but it's extremely difficult to tell
somebody these things it's almost a
difficult is staring at your neighbor
while naked and bathing right but
sometimes you have to do these things
and good things do happen but you got to
get over that hump right and you know I
maybe I'm conflating things here but I
remember early on in in our marriage
Chrissy would be invited to a lot of
parties and because what they'll do is
it'll be for like selling kitchenware or
I remember as a kid me and mom and Jimmy
and Emmy the four of us went to this
like party where that there there like
got all these fancy pots and pans and
they talk about the pots and pans for so
long we were invited to a dinner party
where's the dinner it was no dinner it
was just pots and pans now they were
cooking a bunch of stuff but we weren't
allowed to eat it three hours after we
thought we would have been eating we're
freakin starving we are you're looking
at empty things that could have food in
them they started making dinner and then
it's just like by the time we got the
meal it was the best thing I've ever
eaten because I was about to die of
starvation it's like 10 o'clock at night
well they wear you down so you say sure
whatever I'll join ya give me the dadgum
spaghetti and I was like and you start
to become like your brain became mush
and by the end of it was like a police
interrogation
we're blah we have we're buying the pots
and pans my mom hungry and
you're buying him because the food taste
is so good it was just like but
basically we just we would just just
survived a near-death experience so oh
my god thank you all for these pots and
pans we got we got to bring this home
and there's these freaking jewelry
parties and when Kris and I especially
earlier on in our marriage we were on a
tight budget and I remember you know me
I'm very I'm very frugal really and it
would just get my goat when Christy
would come back from these parties with
her friends and everyone would have been
highly pressured had to buy some had to
buy something else
and if I bought if I bought enough then
so and so who hosted the party you know
she's not doing well financially so it's
like I think those young couples are
really really susceptible to this
because again you're I bought more it
would help her and then I'm like but we
don't have the money for this you were
guilted into buying things but because
of groupthink
yeah it's that kind of like couples in
their 20s is like that's where a lot of
it gets started because you're all
trying to figure out a way to make more
money I understand them the motivation
and you're like we kind of got to find
something else we got to supplement what
we got going on and I'm not saying that
just across the board there's not a
healthy way for this type of company to
exist where you're kind of using word of
mouth and different because listen
there's all kinds of ways to sell people
on something I think it's the fact that
the main Avenue by which these things
work is through friendships and you
can't just say hey don't don't do that
because what I would say is don't do
this with friendships that you value
because but if they said that at the big
feel-good seminar that you go to then
who you only try this with people who
you don't really care about the
friendship well that's not gonna work
because those people don't trust you as
much and and let's see let's get it yeah
they they build a entire social
construct and an identity structure
around being involved in the MLM when
and again this this goes back to my
escape as a kid in our family now my
stepdad at the time Jimmy he
he was he he wasn't he was a drafter
wasn't coming you he wasn't an architect
but he did draft wasn't you know he was
a draftsman draftsman in in the big city
or Ollie he'd go up there and he like he
would draft all these plans and it was
it was a cool freaking job I remember
going in there and seeing and everything
he was drawing it was amazing I don't
remember what happened to that job but I
maybe he was unhappy maybe maybe I I
can't remember why he stopped doing that
but then there was a period where it was
like okay now he's a plumber you know
which is amazing that I mean the dude
went and he knew another trade and he or
he figured it out and he was as far as I
can remember doing pretty well but
apparently not well enough to not do
other things like I remember he was also
for while he was selling vacuum cleaners
door-to-door rainbows
not rainbow he was selling Kirby Kirby
vacuum cleaners like heavy ass vacuum
cleaners like I'm talking like a 50 pet
well there was water Doster there big
barrel barrel water based no no rainbows
water base but the Kirby was just it was
like heavy steel Kirby just have just
heavy no water involved now in
door-to-door salesmen that I mean well
that's uh that made me make people feel
uncomfortable but that's not sacrificing
friendships I I don't understand
door-to-door salesmen I I respect the
fact that to to support his family he
was doing he was exploring many options
to pull it together and you know selling
vacuum cleaners door-to-door it cannot
be an easy job you know and there's a
lot of pressure involved in that and
like going just knocking on people's
doors and then find yourself in their
house vacuuming you know when trying to
sell them this really expensive vacuum
cleaner I mean it's a lot more expensive
than the ones that you could buy it
Kmart or Sky City it's not as heavy
those are not as heavy and you know
there are there's not as much of that
going on the Cutco knives thing is still
happening in the first year of marriage
Chrissy and I bought a whole water Cutco
knives which by the way we still
you can't go out to people's doors in
general and now you can make
appointments for selling things but you
can't just go out of people's doors not
anymore man my point is I'm you know I
don't want to over criticize my ex
stepdad Jimmy for getting involved in
the MLM that he did because he was
trying lots of things to pull it
together for the for the fam you know so
I give him credit for that but we found
ourselves involved in he became an
insurance salesman so again by mostly by
appointments and referrals he was
meeting with people to sell term life
insurance through what was called al
Williams at the time now it's called
Primerica and if you look on Wikipedia
I just wanted to verify that it was a
multi-level marketing organization yeah
it actually also says in the Wikipedia
that a few years back Forbes ranked in
the top 50 most trusted I think it was
insurance companies well and again that
goes back to what we talked about before
so regardless of the the marketing
methods it is a good product that's what
that is saying right again it doesn't
mean that the product is bad right I and
I used to think that I used to think
that there must be something wrong with
this product if it has to be sold in
this high-pressure way versus just being
on the Shelf with other products but no
it's just a different way to do it so it
doesn't mean which is very when it comes
to the great insurance when it comes in
especially when it comes to something
like sports drinks and supplements or
cleaners like with Amway it's like well
I can just go to Target you know it's
like why do I have to be why do I have
to experience this higher pressure in my
home or sales pitch for something that I
can just get off of a shelf and the
reason why is because you know the
prices are higher for something that you
could you could get off Amazon but again
they're they're trying to work the
margins because and they're also trying
to get you to sell it so it's the system
generates money for I guess the people
at the top but the the fact of the
matter is a lot of people get involved
in these
things they just they just fizzle out
but there's a whole world bit around it
where you show up at conventions and you
start to start to feel good about it
like as a kid I knew who this guy al
Williams was it's like man he started
this company
here's his success story Jimmy really
bought into it we went down to Boca
Raton Florida and there was this like
really fancy hotels and they were all
pink like the slime in my shower in it I
was like wow this is amazing
it was one of the first times we had
been on vacation as a family right but
he had to go to all these pep talks
seminars and oh if we were really lucky
you could get to see that al Williams
himself mm-hmm and at one of these
things he was like a he was like a
celebrity these people they were like
okay you got to stay through Sunday but
we'll have a church service for any of
you who want to go to that and they
would like became this little this
community like again a lot of times some
sort of faith component gets inserted
into this because it begins to permeate
so many aspects of your life in your
relationship so why not add that
component because all that does is
generate even more community feel what
it makes you feel good about what yeah
part of a family or a part of this thing
in it but it start I mean it's even at
that young age is like I remember things
that now I interpret is just I felt
weird as a kid because it's like I mean
cultish is a strong word but it has a
little bit of that vibe where it's like
I don't know I anytime I always get
really uncomfortable when people start
trying to combine faith with consumerism
like that that seems like a real special
kind of not good yeah you know and I'm
not saying they were doing like church
services and touting their insurance
within it but there's this their other
tire line mething that's why other we
are we are so good and we're good for
you and we're good for people that we're
doing these type of things and you know
that there's usually someone or groups
of people with success stories that are
tremendous they're like gifted
motivational speakers so they
sell all this hope just like the flip
book with the with the mansions and the
cars and stuff and it's like you know if
you're if you down on your locker if you
don't have direction and you need you
need some you need to scratch it
together and get everything you get you
get a community you get to make a living
you get this there's no doubt that this
is an attractive thing to a lot of
people that's why so many of them are
super successful and so and so then it
becomes this odd evangelistic component
of going back to the people that you're
trying to sell and you're no longer
selling them a product you're selling
them a lifestyle of either being rich or
being happy or be you know it's like you
start to take that out that energy out
to people but when you're when those
people have nothing to do with the thing
the first thing they experience is just
this freaking weird well because most it
most people are able to pick up on an
agenda and and for good reason
we don't like it when we feel like
someone's actions are motivated by an
agenda that we don't quite yet know what
it is when you send me a message on
Facebook I sense that there's an agenda
but you're not sharing that with me when
you invite me out to lunch it seems a
little bit weird there's some sort of
agenda but I won't find out until you
break out the weird presentational
booklet and that's just not a healthy
way to navigate friendships friendships
and relationships are difficult as it is
when you bring this other layer of
agenda into it it's going to make things
more complex and you cannot blame
someone for having a problem with it and
being like I don't want to be your
friend anymore or I definitely don't
want our friendship to be characterized
by this so for for us I mean I only
remember going to that one seminar that
was a vacation where it was like we
didn't get to do a whole lot of vacation
because it was like I had to stand
outside of these meetings that they were
having yeah it was a very focused quite
a down it seemed much at Boka or baton
I remember that Jimmy had an office that
was had a
all slew of paperwork and then you know
stuff he was trying to get off the
ground associated with this thing
Ida he would there would be some people
that he would get to like work
underneath him but I don't recall any of
that really taking hold I remember there
were certain people that he seemed to
idolize within the higher-ups within the
organization that were like okay the guy
who brought me in the guy who brought
him in the guy who brought him in I'm
actually gonna get to meet today and
there was it was just like this
weirdness you know that was like how did
it end for us
I I don't well I think to put it simply
they got a mom and him got a divorce and
we moved out now I saw an interview but
I I don't I don't I don't think it had
anything to do with the involve the al
Williams or Primerica or whatever it's
called now did not have anything to do
with their divorce or their breakup I
think it was totally separate and I just
think it's simply fizzled out after a
while of it not working a couple of
years it's just like this isn't working
for me what am i doing you got to buy in
fully and those who do buy in can
experience a lot of success they can get
that car in that house there's just a
lot that comes along with it but so so
my language is a little overblown that
we escaped as if it were a cult but I do
feel like it was I mean we were when you
go into that pink hotel and you're going
all the seminars and you're bought in we
would definitely bought in for a little
while if I made it out but we made it
out now you know how we feel about it
but I think that the you know the answer
for sneaking in is you just you have to
be honest you got to say I don't want
our relationship to be characterized by
this if you can bring yourself to that
otherwise you're just going to sort of
the relationship will probably just
dwindle my summary critique of it is if
it's more about recruiting people to do
something that you are also doing
instead of the product itself if you
can't just isolate the product on the
open market and give it an honest
comparison and it wins then you
shouldn't believe in the product enough
to pour your whole life and change your
whole life
around it I mean it's a bunch of smoke
and mirrors it's it's selling a bunch of
false hope boil it down to the product
and make a make an honest assessment of
it do you have to have these vitamins in
this energy drink and are you real are
you drinking their kool-aid or should
you actually just compare it to kool-aid
is there a cool ID is there a kool-aid
one because I might join that one
kool-aid with a/c it's like they went
I'm creative well we took a long time on
that one
so let's list listen matters let's
answer another one here from Rachael
Daniels which this one is boy this is so
close to home for me what is the best
way to sign off an email I always say
thanks but what about best or regards
how do I know what's a problem I have
thought about this thoroughly now I
can't just start by giving what my
practice is and I feel stupid about this
okay I just feel dumb what I do is
thanks with an exclamation point and I
do it that's what I do almost always
even though if I'm not thanking you for
anything and then sometimes I won't do
an exclamation point if I feel
especially like I'm really there's
nothing I'm thankful for at all so I
guess I'm thanking you for reading to
this point I - if I'm going to sometimes
I'll just sign it link and then the
third alternative is just read there's
nothing and then I feel like I'm being
cold I'm not being warm like that in a
reply or a chain in that point or I
might actually just drop my signature it
could they know where it comes from it
in one sense it's like when my dad puts
love dad on a text it's like dad I know
where it's I see that it's coming from
you yeah emails work the same way do we
really have to have a Sephora's at the
top well I put it at the bottom now my
default is to say thanks comma and then
put link underneath book and I'm
probably done that and I'm just in terms
of what I'm thinking them before I'm
thanking them for taking the time to get
that far in the email to actually read
it it's not about the content of the
email it's okay apparently you've read
it to this one but sometimes you are
thinking them for something so what if
you are thinking them for something do
you say thanks for that and then you're
like thanks for reading the email
do you blow up or is it just two
all-purpose things no because that's
confusing have you tried best or kind
regards or sincerely sincerely sounds
like a letter not an email I have
friends who use best and there are lots
of people that I respect use best and I
think the only reason I can't use best
is that it's such a foreign thing to the
way that I think and speak like him like
no one said best girl growing up like it
would be well why is it it's like when
all of a sudden somebody says I want you
to call me Ricky instead of Richard III
why you know I I can't start using best
what is he trying to prove it almost
feels like you at the end of your email
you would sign like James McLaughlin
it's not that it's false but it's not
what you go by I do think it's also my
middle name in my last name I know I'm
just saying it wouldn't be false but it
would be a little weak or a large hopper
RJ yeah it's just I do feel like same
best is that weird because my criteria
for the tone of my emails is if I had to
if I was standing beside you as you read
this and I was reading out loud to you
and I would have said deadly ones in
regards it did yeah it's it's but I
think the flip side of this cuz I'm I'm
on your side but the flip side is where
we are pointing out the lost art of the
written letter
Lando's teacher invites people to
friends and family members to write
letters to the address to the kid in the
class through the school because she
wants to teach kids the lost art of
letter writing and whenever kids get a
letter there she's like they're so
excited okay this letter times some
people have got letters a parent can
write a letter but goes to the school or
like a grandparent or yeah yeah just
okay got it
I've been writing your kids for years
okay good best it is the best and but
then she said what they don't know is if
they do get a letter
then I make them write a letter back and
I have to learn what that's like
I think that we're applying this
colloquial conversational criteria to
two email signatures because we don't
appreciate the fact there's a there's
nothing wrong with the formality of the
of a letter and I think best
I mean you hated sincerely but is it
just gone or is it something that we
should try to embrace and open up to as
an answer to this question
sincerely link well you know I feel like
sometimes I and I think this applies to
texts as well you know like if you were
to write thanks period at the end of
your email yeah it would send a little
bit of a shudder through something what
did I do wrong I'll reread this email
he's you know because of the period a
period yeah and I don't I I track with
what you're saying but I feel like
trying to somehow recapture the essence
of letter writing and then some and put
that back into emails it we're beyond
that gone first of all I don't think
that our kids use email I think email is
becoming almost exclusively a business
thing mm-hm and because the way that it
keeps a it keeps the threads together
and you can group things and it's the
kind of way when you need to communicate
about something business ish or business
like you need to communicate in that way
and then some people are you know I
don't really know what the criteria is
for me deciding to send a slack message
to someone here at work or to send an
email but I will say that I often
because you can just as easily create a
group a group in the same way that you
can create a group on email well what
I'm getting at is I don't you know what
the application for this will be because
I think that all the emails that I send
at this point are either I'm sure okay
like alright I'm gonna have this thing
at my house
and I don't want to go to through the
formality of creating an evite for it or
something like that it's just like hey
I'm sending you information and then
what do I say at the end of it if it's
to a bunch of friends I'll I'll sign off
in some way that's just supposed to be
fun and cute and funny but I don't have
a default for me this is what do I say
when I send a business email and I know
that if I just transition completely to
best it would be like mmm okay he's got
he's got his he's buttoned up there's
something cool about best though because
it says no matter maybe it's the best
response I hated it when we first
started talking about it but just hear
me out
any written word is open to so much
misinterpretation you know and I it
burdens me that some so many things
happen over text or email that with a
simple face-to-face conversation or even
a phone call crises could have been
averted left and right misinterpretation
feelings being hurt
you know restless nights of analyzation
of what did what did he mean what it
it's so and so upset there was a period
at the end of the thanks you know mm-hmm
you know you the simple four-letter
words best really captures no no matter
what you you think or might have read
between the lines or have interpreted
from what I've written just know that my
intentions were good I meant I only
meant okay listen let's examine a test
case because I don't agree with you on
this because if I write you an email in
it the last sentence in the email is and
that's why I think you're an ass mm-hmm
gosh
yeah I'm saying it like I mean that
doesn't work understanding it personally
first of all when I did get that email
from you I didn't even notice the
closing because I said thanks with an
exclamation point because I do it out of
habit I'm just trying to give it its
best shot because I do think it's a
problem I don't think there's an answer
I mean I hate to be there was say that
if there was an ending that could do
what best is trying to do I would be off
for it
but I think we're so self-aware and
we're so judgmental as people that like
we always it's like well that's that's
that's weird that's pretentious it's not
something you would say so why time it
regards yeah yeah it's like get off your
high horse or get in the real world like
we're just communicating here but you be
normal how about just like what are you
in an MLM or something here's the thing
at this point I don't think you it's not
this isn't this situation where you can
invent a new phrase because then you're
just weird like if I was just like you
know what I'm gonna do when I get done
with an email I'm just gonna be like yep
rent quark oh it's almost like you're
like freaking corkle times yep would
work cuz it would be like it you know
how like okay
that's how much cuz I also I'm the guy
that usually if I'm not too busy I read
through the email that I just typed to
make sure that it doesn't say something
crazy and so I read back through it and
I'm like yep send you know oh sure
this is more like it's what you actually
yes that's what I meant to say Rhett
signature then white on why don't you
just type okay Cindy now pressing send
how about this message has it been
approved by Rhett mcLaughlin
oh gosh that's sad that feels yeah it'd
be an automatic signature or something
it's like it that's like a dad joke
whose kids decided not to talk to him
five years ago you know what about sent
from my phone because that still has the
automatic signature on my emails on my
phone get rid of that crap that is done
people sent from my phone is just an
excuse for not rereading the email or
not taking the time to write
just who no one cares about email don't
I don't apologize for something you
don't know if you said I've gotten so
close to taking cent from my phone first
of all it used to say like sent from my
iphone or right is that was a default
and that that felt pretty pretentious I
have an iPhone
now mine just says sent from my phone
and the reason that I have not taken it
out of there is because autocorrect man
sometimes your phone will do something
that your keyboard would never do hmm
and so it's just like did he just does
he want me to kill the whale I don't or
do you want me to save the whale I don't
I don't have anything I just tested
myself there's nothing I don't I don't
have a signature on my phone I don't
even have a signature well my work stuff
I have a signature yeah but and I
understand like we've got a lot of
people here who have Sigma sorry I'm
just deleting emails now again and
they've got like you know you've got
like the mythical entertainment you know
logo and you've got your title and
you've got your contact information
that's I think that's important
depending on you know what your job is
here's what I think you should be but
that's not a signature well here's what
that it no that's a signature that's not
a that's not what do you call it what is
the sign-off I think the sign-off here's
my but note they're supposed salutation
there's a what if that's the opening
hello what is the correct letter term
for that though see we've lost all this
you should know this this is the kind of
thing that you would remember from
school the nose teacher the closing of a
letter is called the the D citation
desalinization i I don't know what it's
called but this is what I think it
should be I think when you read back
through your email you get in the rhythm
of hey I'm reading this I'm thinking I'm
putting my mind in the headspace of the
person who's receiving this I'm reading
back through it to make sure nothing
dumb is in there
and then when I get to the bottom what
do I having gotten the momentum of just
reading back through it when you get to
the what do you call it complementary
closer closing complementary closing now
remember that the valediction I was a
valedictorian of my high school class
you read back through it and you're like
getting the vibe putting yourself in
their shoes and then you just whatever
you feel like you would have said if you
would have given that as a speech you
say it at that point Thanks yep
yeah see Nate hitting send now you're
100% right I mean just whatever you feel
it's added on it's never the same
sometimes it might be best sometimes it
might be a middle finger emoji do they
make that yeah yeah that Jenna is is
adamantly nodding yes is that yours is
that your complimentary closing a middle
finger emoji what is yours
I mean you're our assistant you get your
communicating on our behalf what is your
closing you know what time it is
Thanks exclamation point the last email
she sent to us was thanks with an
exclamation point
you are usually asking us to do
something though yes our job is more
about you asking us to do things and
then asking you Thanks exclamation point
is more like in anticipation of your
compliance I am thanking you right
here's all the things that you guys
should be doing that I've asked you
about thanks for trying
I think you just need to know I think
that works I think you're doing great
but if you don't put anything you're you
are a jerk you see it's eat you might be
seen as a jerk well he just son Rhett no
he didn't even take the time to put a
complimentary closing every time
somebody does that though I respect him
though it's just like I said what I
wanted to say it's like I just want you
to remember who said it's a power play
it's like staring at someone from your
shower see I don't need more power I've
got so much but it was just the the
staring eyes emoji can just translate
into an email is there I'm always wash
our naked I'll be
watching you I don't know that we've
helped in this one but we got a stop
I'll never delete this if you're keeping
a record of this hashtag your biscuits
give us your complimentary closing and
why it's the best if you don't think
it's best we tried we tried so hard to
get to give you what you needed to give
you an answer sorry Rachel Daniels link
went out there you've believed so hard
and best but I dismantled it very
quickly and now we're left with it's
what you make it man all to make it I
always the best
always always always that's a bit too
love letter ish hmm how about alway all
those all the way all the way best all
the way okay I don't think we've he'll I
think love you know I could use a little
bit more love I put look I'd say love to
my to my mom if I send an email what
about for a whole month every email you
send no matter to who it is that you
love if you just love I was like a david
dobrik bet okay you don't want it okay
well then maybe that maybe it would be
good this right yeah people use a lot I
don't think david dobrik would do an
email prank
hashtag your biscuits let us know what
you think about all the stuff if you
want to defend MLM go for it my
recommendation I'll keep it quick is Ken
Burns country music I've been watching
that you know every episode is I think
there's eight of them it's a documentary
on the meticulous development of the
amazing and best
I wouldn't say best genre I can't say
that I was just trying to work best in
but it's it's I'm very fond of the Jon
one of the better John Rose country
music lotsa Merle Haggard one of his
last interviews before his death it was
tough to watch the first episode because
I was you know since he's passed but
it's cool it's cool to see him he's got
that gleam in his eye how many hours of
the commitment is this probably 16
18 yeah so that's my recommendation go
to pbs.org
look for your local listing if you want
to stream it and they're not showing
anymore you have to give him a little
donation but hey it's worth it
Kim burns was thinking about watch time
before YouTube yeah he was all right
willing of watch time will speak at you
next week
thanks for hanging out and if we
offended you what you know what just
okay just introspect a little bit yeah
I'll meet you at the Barnes & Noble in
the coffee shop I'll be the one with a
cardboard prop up for my presentation to
watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best